so I'm going to be talking to all of you
about project oh there it goes I just
need to get a little closer we're going
to be talking about project cannot these
which is an source well you try a little
lower
there we go maybe I'll switch to a mic I
can try holding it okay we'll see if it
works for is an open source astronomy
project also citizen science and all
that kind of good stuff and it does a
way that all of you can help us as
humans we can all the worlds together
but first before I get into that side I
think we can all agree on something
you're kind of self selected by coming
here
yeah space and astronomy are pretty cool
thing and I have thought about this like
all my life I was one of those weird
kids that like watched Nova after Sesame
Street and didn't realize it wasn't
children's programming and then I like
convinced my father to read me from a
cosmology textbook instead of like
bedtime stories yeah wasn't that weird
and there's good reason for that a lot
of stuff was just around about the space
of attack because growing up a lot of
stuff was still in that kind of the
collective consciousness of the adults
around it was things like the lunar
landing demand missions smooth we're
still pretty fresh in people's mind
minds of the teachers around me and the
minds of my parents and it had just been
really recent that we had seen the first
pictures
surface of other planets like this is
from the Viking one Lander in 1974 and
1976 sorry and this is a picture from
the surface of Mars and that's really
really really cool
and these really cool things kept
happening throughout my childhood and it
influenced me like this is a picture
some of you might recognize the
important thing is to ignore the colored
streaks they're not the important part
that's glare because the camera is
looking kind of close there's a little
tiny dot in this picture that you can
probably barely make out on the
projected screen and if any of you were
around Earth in February of 1991 this is
a picture of all of us this is the
Voyager spacecraft towards the end of
the life of its cameras they turned it
around and they took a picture of Earth
as well as the other planets so it's
kind of like a old-school selfie I guess
if you had really long arms holding the
Voyager spacecraft and the exciting news
just kept on coming and this one even
kind of got me into some trouble because
my bedtime stories were like astronomy
news and cosmology textbooks I was up on
the news apparently a little head of my
teachers and in school we were learning
about the nine planets because there
were nine back then and I insisted that
they were they were wrong there were 10
planets
we had just discovered another one
really far away and my teacher didn't
agree with me or the way I educated my
fellow students about it I got into a
little bit of trouble for the insolence
but it was worth it this planet by the
way has a wonderful name of a PSR be one
two five seven plus twelve it's a cool
planet around a pulsar really far away
and these things are really cool and
they influenced me a lot as I grew up it
got me super excited about space and
things but all of these things from the
manned missions to the moon to like this
pulsar planet discovery they also heard
one thing in common that was a little
bit of a buzzkill
they were all super expensive projects
which means of all the thousands of
people involved and like the manda
missions to the moon only a very few
people got to go and actually get to
walk around and with a lot of these
experiments you needed to devote your
life to get the time on expensive fancy
instruments to be able to do your
research and I like kind of faster
satisfaction the kind of satisfaction we
get from web dev and software
development today so my life went in a
little bit of a different direction and
I guess I'll introduce myself before I
go any further so these days I spend my
time doing security advocacy at Google
so a different direction the space stuff
but I remain kind of an astronomy geek
the whole time kind of always kept an
eye on the news and all that kind of
stuff and recently I've had an
opportunity as a regular software
engineer tech person to get involved in
actual research and that's what I'm
going to be sharing with you today
specifically I'm gonna break it down
this way here's our agenda thingy we're
gonna spend just a moment talking about
exoplanet science and why now is such an
exciting time in the field and then no
talk about astronomy or I guess
spider-man movie would be complete
without an origin story so we're gonna
do an origin story of the penalty's
project to kind of explain why it exists
and what's special about it then we'll
spend a few minutes talking about the
hardware that makes it possible because
half of the project is the hardware
that's kind of unique to the project and
the other half of the project is the
open science experiment the science
we're doing with that hardware and then
hopefully if I've inspired all of you
the last part will be telling you what
we're doing next which will hopefully
involve your contributions at least some
of you so that further ado let's do some
exoplanet science stuff so way back in
like 1995 as I mentioned we discovered
reconfirm the first exoplanet people had
been talking about exoplanets for a long
time they had prophesized they existed
we didn't have a lot of concrete data
and early on the discovery process was
quite slow but as the years passed we
came up with new clever ways to infer
their existence from like very thin
amounts of data and as it turns out
they're kind of everywhere like at this
point it's looking pretty likely that
their planets run almost every star out
there every time there's a star system
errs I go there can never be a planet
around a close binary star system like
in Star Wars like oh no we found some or
like oh there can never be you know
planets around a star this this young or
contains this this composition of
minerals we actually find those two so
it seems like every time we turn the
corner we find more and I'm gonna talk a
little about the different techniques
we've used and there's actually this is
kind of a sample of it because there's a
whole bunch of clever ways people have
figured out that either do work for
discovery or so planets or may work in
the near future but these are a few I've
picked just to kind of go through to
kind of set the stage on the science so
the first is direct observation like why
don't we just try and look at them
directly like we look at stars directly
and nebula and other cool things why
don't we just look at planets around
other stars you know it kind of seems
obvious then I'm going to spend some
time talking about Doppler spectroscopy
which is the technique that was most
productive until about 2012 or so and
then the the new technique which is the
one that's super prolific so every time
you see an article where it's like a
thousand new exoplanets discovered
probably by Kepler which is a Space
Telescope those were all done using a
technique called transit photometry
which is coincidentally the technique
that cannot be use is and it's my
favorite one
so why don't we just use the obvious
technique which is why don't we try to
directly observe so this is something I
did you should never do
I took my cell phone camera and I
pointed it at the Sun and I took a
picture don't do that if you value your
cell phone's camera it's really bad for
it but this is an old phone so I didn't
care and like this is our Sun and
there's a good chance that there's a
planet in this picture that we can't see
Venus or mercury might be in this photo
but the Sun is super bright and even
though we're pretty close relative to
exoplanets we're pretty close to the are
the planets in our solar system like
it's almost impossible to see these
under normal normal circumstances just
because there's too much glare and it's
the same kind of problem except way
worse for planets around other stars and
as a result we've directly observed a
very small number of planets around
other stars it's because it's very hard
here's one example of a planet we have
observed this is from alt B and this was
done using the Hubble Space Telescope
which is above the atmosphere and can
get really sharp pictures and it took
several years for us to confirm this so
even if we take like a piece of metal
and we block out the star itself to kind
of make an artificial Eclipse there's
still a whole bunch of glare and other
light that kind of gets in the way but
in the despite that we did manage to
find this planet it just looks like a
little tiny nodule net noise is kind of
moving along and today we're at the
point where some of the most powerful
ground-based telescopes in the world can
directly image a very small number of
planets in special circumstances but
this is not not going to work for
finding all of them this is not going to
work for a broad survey it's just too
expensive and it requires instruments
like the Hubble Space Telescope which is
very expensive so knowing that this
technique was probably going to be
ineffective we needed to come up with
clever ways to kind of infer that they
exist via other signals and this is
where a Doppler Doppler spectroscopy
difficult to say but pretty effective
came into play and this technique
in furs that existence of other planets
by using rainbows which is pretty fun
because it turns out that if you take
light from a star and you shine it
through a prism or a spectroscope in
this case you get a rainbow out rainbows
have a little variation depending on the
star if the star is red the red parts of
the rainbow will be brighter the star is
blue the blue parts of the rainbow will
be a little brighter there's also these
notches that show up and the reasons for
these notches showing up is a little bit
complicated and I'm not going to get
into it but the notches are there and
one of the cool these little notches
it's if you reproduce them in a
laboratory environment you get very
clean edges and they stay precisely in
the right spot with a very high degree
of precision and we can take advantage
of this because in the lab they seem to
stay perfectly still but for a lot of
stars they kind of wiggle around a very
small amount and by small amount I mean
like a really small amount I mean like
for an individual sample maybe a
thousandth of a pixel on our MA highest
resolution spectroscopes so very very
small amounts but we get enough samples
we can add them up and we can detect
this wiggling and what this wiggling is
is a Doppler shift which is a similar
experience like white is affected by the
same thing as that goes past you and you
hear the pitch change as it approaches
you and goes away thing happens to light
and we use this for all sorts of things
in astronomy but we can also use it to
infer those existence of planets because
stars use gravity to hold their planets
in and they're holding their planet in
by tugging it and although the planets
are the planet also tugs on the star so
the star will move back and forth a
little bit as that planet moves around
it's actually moving in a circle but to
us it looks like it's kind of wiggling
back and forth because we can't see the
side-to-side motion and the amount of
motion we're able to detect is very
small we're actually down to the point
where we can detect less than a meter
per second of motion of a star so like
imagine an unimaginably giant star and
it's moving we can detect movement
that's roughly as fast as I'm walking
across the stage right now of that
entire object which is pretty cool
technique and it works in a large number
of extrasolar systems but it has a
notable downside which requires very
expensive telescopes to look at
generally one object at a time and take
many samples over a large period of time
so it's expensive and we have to like
there's a lot of stars out there to look
at one at a time and that brings us to
the third technique I'm going to talk
about tree and this is the technique
that the Kepler space telescope used
which is a another space telescope that
did a survey it spent a lot of time
staring at a chunk of the sky about as
big as your hand and it found a whole
bunch of exoplanets using this technique
it could look at several stars in that
area all at once and this technique is
all about counting photons because when
you look at a star generally like stars
have a lot of reasons to vary but the
light from most stars are gonna stay
relatively constant that is until
something new so for example in 2012 in
our little solar system an object planet
Venus and when so if you're looking at
our own star and our own planet you can
actually see the disk move past it other
star systems are too far away for that
so the star just looks a little bit
dimmer because it's kind of like a point
source it's a single pixel on our camera
and that single pixel gets a tiny amount
dimmer and what's cool about that dip is
it depends on the size of the planet how
close it is to the star and the size of
the star itself how bright the star is
this at dimming
so which is a huge signal compared to
the other techniques we've used in the
past that is the kind of technique that
you might be able to detect using
consumer electronics like the SLR is you
can go buy at the store and that's where
a pen optics comes in so around the time
people were figuring out the photometry
was a useful technique for detecting
planets around other stars and digital
cameras were getting really good it's a
group of astronomers down in Hawaii and
they were like I wonder if this works
and one notable person group
Olivia Aegon the founder of the project
is also a little bit of a hacker kind of
like us so he did the obvious thing he
dove into his garage and ripped a bunch
of stuff out of on other projects there
scooped up other stuff flying around and
maybe cut up a washing machine which he
won't tell me if it was working before
he started or not he covered it in zip
ties and tape and bolted it to the side
of his house to see if it would work
thoughts were pretty promising promising
enough that he was able to convince an
observatory on Mauna Loa in Hawaii to
give us some space and other people to
join the project and help him out so for
the next several we thought we
experimented with immersive cameras
because you have the you have we and it
different you know do expensive lenses
work our expensive lens is worth the
amount of money our cheap lens as best
we refine the controls so that we can do
the robotic observation better the
software behind it and another important
part is we were using
devices called an equatorial mount which
is what's aiming the camera at the side
of the sky great a lot of things
including tape and like rubber seals and
that kind of stuff and after a while
it's like this allowed us to kind of
home in on finding out what the kind of
the sweet spot is on the hardware and
along the way we got to take some really
cool pictures so while we were
experimenting with different exposure
settings what looks likely to turn out
pretty well on the sides some cool
things like this one we took a picture
that contained Comet Lovejoy and a
Geminoid media are in the same exposure
that was pretty cool we also got some
picture of the Orion Nebula next to the
Horsehead Nebula so I guess it's Orion's
belt and this one's my favorite we did a
really long exposure and we were pointed
at the Virgo cluster and it turns out
you can make out the shape of galaxies
from a photo taken with a consumer SLR
which is something that completely blew
me away so it's time to ask me homes in
on like what is the perfect harder for
this experiment because if you can make
it cheap we can hopefully convince
people to build more of them and then
have a whole lot of them and that's
where the baseline unit design comes in
I think of it as kind of our v 1.0
hardware kind of a you know if you think
of semantic versioning for for robotic
observatories so the goals of our
baseline we wanted something that is
based off of one of our more
commercially available off-the-shelf
components we want you to be able to go
to a store buy things you need to build
it and like put them together yourself
we wanted the build materials to be
roughly we're getting and this worked
out well because it allows it puts it
within the realm of Education which is
something we're all so passionate about
we want this to be something that not
only educational institution
rich countries can build but we want
this to be something that's reach of
education Zinn like developing countries
in other parts of the world because the
more places which will get and the
better the science will be we wanted
this to be built with simple cool
assembled open options based on unit
using only hand tools and then a couple
of times although a drill press does
help and we wanted the skill set
required to be something that's with the
realm of experience of like a high
school robotics team be able to assemble
it although based on a lot of the
robotics they're pretty good and of
course we wanted all the design to be
open source so that someone could take
this and if they don't want to
participate in the survey our primary
experiment they can use it for something
else because that would be cool too this
is part of our baseline unit this is the
the meat of it the thing that does the
observing as it turns out cheap SLRs
worked great for this so we we
originally use canon SL ones which is
about the cheapest SLR body you can buy
it's also wonderfully lightweight being
made out of mostly plastic and now we're
using the canon SL 2 because the SL 1
got end of life and the SL 2 is are
pretty much a drop-in replacement for
our purposes it turns out that cheap
lenses are the sweet spot so we're using
some off-brand 85 millimeter prime
lenses which are pretty low cost and
some other commercial off-the-shelf
stuff to turn those on and off and copy
data off of them the electronics that
make it up include some some some stuff
that people assemble on perfboard
there's a single PCB that we ship out to
teams that are doing builds for power
control but you could definitely build
that off of perfboard also all the
electronics components are things like
sensors you could get from Adafruit or
DF robot some relays capacitors arduino
z' all through-hole soldering so this is
something that's within the reach of
someone doing their first soldering
project and a few other components like
eka an off-the-shelf equatorial mount
meant for like consumer as for
astronomical photography and an Intel
nook to control it all and do some of
the pre-processing and this is what it
kind of
together to look like so this is the
very first prototype getting I think
it's on this is a fourth or fifth
revision depending on where you decide
to count them going to our first
baseline design to test it we call this
particular robot lovingly call it pan
zero zero one because we're astronomers
and we name things like that and it's
performed pretty well up Oman Aloha it
has definitely gone through the weather
testing it has experienced a hundred and
40 mile-per-hour winds
tons of UV exposure that white case used
to be brown and it's actually been
snowed on and throughout all of that
it's actually been been pretty reliable
and this is a pretty big observation
because traditionally a lot of these
instruments are housed inside domes to
protect them but we didn't want domes
because domes are expensive and they're
hard to get working and they break all
the time
and it worked great so for the last year
or so we have been expanding our network
of robotic telescopes so we have three
of them online right now one in
Australia the original one pan zero zero
one in Hawaii and then another one
outside of Boston up in Massachusetts we
also have four more telescopes that are
in progress of construction including
one in Arizona that'll be the first one
built by a high-schooler which is pretty
cool and mine which is going slower than
the one being built by the high schooler
it's making a little progress and then
we also have like six or seven more
teams that are in different stages of
acquiring the components with plans to
start it at the beginning of the next
academic school year so this fall we're
expecting more to go online in a bunch
of different locations including Italy
until they should be pretty exciting so
that's the robot hopefully I've
convinced you that it's capable of
taking pictures of the sky but that's
only like half of the whole project the
other half is taking those pictures and
from those pictures figuring out there
are planets around other stars the
science side and this is kind of how we
go about it so each one of the robotic
telescopes has like a hard-coded list of
objects that we find interesting to
represent kind of the center of the
frames we're going to look at their the
objects we focus on not the only objects
verbs are
serving but they're kind of we got to
Center our frames on something and
thanks to awesome open-source libraries
what you can do is you can just list the
catalog name of stars and then if you
know like which way north is I don't
know if that's north and where you are
on the planet you can figure out if
those objects are in a good portion of
the sky to look at so when it starts off
when it wakes up at the beginning of the
night it will go through its list of
interesting objects some of which are in
your hemisphere and some of which may
not be visible to you ever it'll find
that the first one it can observe that's
in a good position like near near the
top of the sky where the air mass is low
and it'll look at it for as long as it
can it'll take between 10 and 300
exposures and the number of exposures
depends on your location
and how long the exposures are because
you also have to tune the exposures a
little bit for the light quality so if
you're in an area with more background
light like near a city you're gonna do
like 30th second exposures if you're in
a wonderful location like on top of
Mount Aloha about two minute exposures
seem to work out well and then all those
frames they come out looking like this
this is a raw picture from I think this
one's taken from Mount Aloha for the
pretty fast exposure so these each one
of these frames that we get out we use
the raw image data is about as much sky
as your hand held at arm's length which
is coincidentally the amount of sky that
the Kepler looked at during its lifetime
so we're looking at pretty big chunks of
the sky when we have really good
lighting condition this picture may
contain as many as a hundred thousand
stars so a whole lot of them and one of
the cool things about these same
open-source libraries is you can do the
opposite of what we did earlier you can
take a picture and it will tell you the
catalog name of all of the stars in the
picture although if you have a hundred
thousand it takes quite a while to
figure that part out so we do then is we
figure out the list of objects in these
pictures that we want to look for
planets around so we zoom on in we keep
on zooming way in and we end up with a
tiny cropped picture like this
we call these post
stamp images because we're tiny and
there's probably a couple things you
notice about this first of all I
mentioned that stars are like point
sources of light but that's kind of
smeared around a little bit it's
actually covering like 12 or 13 pixels
in this image and that's because of
that's that atmosphere thing like it
keeps us alive but it really messes with
astronomy stars twinkle and that makes
the light it's kind of danced around our
CCD a little bit unfortunately we're
using pretty we're using cheap SLRs
they're not very many megapixels which
means those pixels are pretty big so
they don't bounce around very many of
them but that's that's something we have
to compensate for but if we were using a
regular Astronomy sensor we would just
add up all of those pixels and it would
give us a pretty good number a pretty
good photometry of measurement but we're
not using regular Astronomy equipment
we're using consumer cameras which have
this thing on them to make our little
images like if you look back at that it
looks kind of like a waffle and that
waffle effect is caused by something
called a Bayer filter and the Bayer
filter is how your camera can take color
photos color filters are wonderful like
those Astrid the photography the
pictures I had earlier on that we took
on of the the nebula and the comet are
really cool and colorful and exciting
and they're great to look at but they
are really bad for science so we have to
compensate for this also and this is
this one's a little more complicated and
one of the things that's more unique to
this project because this is done with a
filter the way a filter works is it
filters out the light you don't want
which is trouble for photometry because
we don't know exactly how many pixels
are how many photons are getting
absorbed by this filter they're gone so
we don't know they don't make a tourist
sensor so we have to do some clever
trickery to compensate so what we do is
fortunately when you have thousands of
stars in a picture you can find your
star and have a certain twinkle and then
you go back over the photo and you find
every other star that has an identical
set of twinkling and it turns out this
happens several times in each one of
these these frames and then what you can
do is you can look up each one of those
stars in the catalog and figure out how
bright it is supposed to be
and then you can solve that equation and
you get out relative brightness between
all those all those stars relative to
what we expect those stars to be based
on prior observations in other words we
get calibration data out you repeat this
process for the same star in each one of
those frames we took the 10 to 300
frames and we get what we call poaches
stamp cubes and this is a whole bunch of
those different craft images for one
star and all the calibration data for
each image and if we take that out we
can do photometry we can generate what's
called a light curve so here's an
example of a light curve produced from a
[ __ ] unit about a month ago by an
intern did some awesome work and so the
little the red line actually represents
what we expect the dimming to be for
this planet so this is a known exoplanet
we used this is actually a calibration
like curve there we reason to calibrate
one of the units and the red line
represents what we expect the the planet
transit to look like the the downward
the slope the first slope apart is where
the planet starts to partially cross the
star the flat bottom part is when the
whole planet is in front of the star and
then that other slope is where it's
starting to exit and then the top flat
line which is mostly cropped off is when
the planet is either away from the star
behind it and the blue dots represent
the samples we get from the penalty's
unit so they're scattered about but we
have a whole bunch of them and we get a
pretty good fit for the curve so the the
curve for this one came out within 1/10
of a percent of the expectation so this
particular one transit has about a 1.3
percent drop in light and we get about
that much so it works
yay oh one thing that's cool about this
picture is this light curve this is the
one of the first ones we collected and
at non-ideal location so this unit was
actually doing observing in the LA basin
which does not have the best atmospheric
conditions I here stone for pollution
sometimes or something and there's some
light pollution because there's some
cities nearby but it's still worked
great so that was really really
wonderful for us to see you're excited
about that
so we have some telescopes up we're
doing a research project we have data
we're sharing with some scientists we're
doing our own research with it what's
happening next in other words how can
all of you help discover new planets so
everyone wants to discover planets right
otherwise why why would you be here
there are other sessions that are
probably cool too
so the first thing we'd love to do is
build the network build a lot more
because we're using we have a lot of low
quality samples but the more penalties
units we have the more samples we have
and the better we can start looking for
planets around more and more smaller
planets around nearby stars and planets
around more distant stars so we'd love
to have a bigger network of conatus
units so this is something that's just
like super excited about consider
building one yourself or do you know
will be even better even better would be
mentoring a mentoring or sponsoring a
school to build one so think about some
are you studied in the past or maybe
some where your kid is studying could
they benefit from a research astronomy
program probably I can't think of one
that couldn't or maybe there's a FIRST
Robotics team you know that is really
bored for some reason they could slap
one of these together super fast so yeah
partner with a nearby educational
institution because one of the things we
love about this is these we hope that
these can be used for that the students
can be involved in doing their own
research and make real progress
themselves and I hear a lot of your
software developers like myself for some
reason I guess it's a software
conference and as all of you know
there's an unlimited number of things we
want software to do there's always more
work to do and this projects no
different we'd love help doing more
software so you want to come and join
the project and help us code on exciting
problems like better scope automation
we'd love help with that or with the
data pipeline to do the like curves this
is an area I'm a little more focused on
and until now we've been doing most of
our research like the final processing
of those light curves just in I PI thon
notebooks because they're a great way to
tinker around but we're finally at the
point relatively recently where we think
it's time to start taking some of the
things we have we
have verified works on small-scale and
start doing it for all of the stars in
all of our photos so to do that we need
a pipeline which will probably involve
serverless and other fun buzzwords and
none of those are too exciting to you
some of the other future projects we
have which have not really been touched
at all are things like a web or mobile
interface for controlling the
telescope's because the exoplanet
research is kind of like the default
mission for these robotic telescopes but
the intent is for them to be
general-purpose instruments so the
school builds it and then maybe
something interesting is happening near
Jupiter or maybe they just want a cool
picture of Saturn or the Orion Nebula we
want them to be able to manually set
other programs on it so then they can
use it to do cool Astro photography or
they can use it to do other research we
haven't thought of like maybe looking
for near-earth objects things like that
which would require slightly different
camera settings so we want to be able to
help take this you know the side quests
from the primary mission and in addition
to being an exoplanet research project
this is also a really big survey and we
want to be able to share all of our
photos with other scientists which we're
already doing right now they're just
living in a Google cloud storage bucket
so they're hanging out and we've given
people access to just like here's our
bucket and they're like ah there's all
sorts of pictures there how do I know
what's what object we don't yet you have
to go figure it out yourself and one
thing we'd love to build at some point
as a science interface so people can be
like give me all of the pictures of this
quality rating from this location of
this object to be able to search through
all of our raw data it may be classify
some of her data to filter out the stuff
that's like oh for some reason the
telescope decided to operate when it was
cloudy despite the cloud unit sensor we
have some of those pictures too so yeah
lots of softer too right and of course I
got to thank everyone who helped make
the project possible
many different organizations have helped
us through grants and other kinds of
support so yeah so if you would like to
learn more about the project go check us
out at project for nappies at org or
check out our forum which is kind of the
most active part of discussion on the
project and if you want these slides for
some reason there there's a PDF of them
up on my website too so thanks so much
and we have a few minutes left so I'm
going to do some questions I'm gonna
look at the slide Oh thing first and
then if anyone has questions you can
throw them in there or you can ask live
so the first question is are you
considering feeding any of your data
into existing projects like Galaxy Zoo
so is that project still active I'm not
sure of God's easy to select I think it
is it is okay it is so we have not
really considered pushing our data
anywhere because each one of the
observing each one of the observatories
like the raw data is about 38 gigs per
night per telescope so pushing that data
around can get kind of expensive but
somebody has an interesting project they
would like to subscribe to our data I'm
sure we right now like all of our data
sharing essentially being done ad hoc on
a case-by-case basis so if anyone's
interested or has some where you think
our data should go let us know and we'll
investigate sharing it manually with
them the next question at what rate does
each new pinaki is going to discover new
planets what is the marginal
contribution of each unit that is a
great question so we are currently in
the phase science moves a little slower
than a lot of software development the
project is about eight years old now and
we're currently in the phase where we're
still refining a lot of our algorithms
so we may have the data that reveals new
exoplanets but right now we're kinda in
the phase where we're focusing on
further proving that our stuff will work
well so we're doing a lot of
verifications of existing known
exoplanets and fortunately there is a
new Space Telescope that went up pretty
recently called tests which is super
exciting especially to us because the
kinds of planets were looking for
overlaps with the kinds of planets Tess
is looking for which is different than
the exoplanets that Kepler was looking
for like we actually can't verify very
many of the Kepler planets but the test
planets are on stars that are closer to
us and have have a have a different
signal that they overlap some more
though so right now we're kind of
focusing on the verification step and as
we move further forward we'll eventually
start especially once you get that data
pipeline going some exoplanets will
probably start coming out which would be
really cool in terms of how the
contributions work out it's kind of like
a sports team
no individual penalties you
is probably going to discover an
exoplanet and although there are going
to be some superstar units like the one
at that awesome location amount Aloha
which gets a hundred thousand stars in
each frame it takes a whole team to for
this project to actually be successful
so especially with the data we're
getting back from like the one in the LA
basin was it was really promising so it
looks like telescope almost anywhere
it's going to be able to contribute and
make a pay piece of a larger discovery
there gonna be some of those points in
that curve that helps us find planets
systems that maybe have several planets
and stuff like that so if there are any
other questions on on on the web thing
so no other questions on here does
anybody have any live questions they'd
like to ask sure
so sorry what was that aha
the question is the is the relative
photometry thing we're doing to
compensate by dupe like doing the
twinkles in the same frame I'm not aware
of anyone else using it right now I'd
have to go back the as far as I know the
first record of it was in the first
cannot use paper but I could prob and
see if anyone signed it and I started
using it it's definitely possible some
of those but there's not really a lot of
need for it unless you're using a CCD
with a bear filter and I think we're the
only ones doing that the question I kind
of sweep across so question is how long
does a transit take is it is it a single
night or will take several observing
sessions that's a great question
it depends a lot there are some of the
easiest ones to find that will actually
transit in a single night because
they're super close to their stars so
they're orbiting like incredibly fast so
there are plenty of cases where we'll
see a transit happen in a single night
and also if they're far away like if the
the planet is far away from the star the
transit will happen for a very small
portion so the transit will often happen
during an observing session what we
found from looking at our recent data is
we usually get part of the transit and
we end up having to cobble together the
whole transit for multiple observing
sessions which is another data
processing challenge because light
conditions change but it depends on the
planet but some of them do happen very
quickly like the the Venus transit
happened in only a few minutes in our
solar system
so the question is is this specific to
the camera we're using the general
technique is not the all the fiddling
we've done to make it work is specific
to our camera so there are some
variations in the way the bayer filters
are laid out so if you were to use this
with a different camera
you'd have to tweak it a little bit and
there are some people who have who are
interested in building a very similar
unit with a different camera and in that
case we're gonna have to tweak the
algorithm to fit there but in the
general purpose it should work for any
camera with a Bayer filter okay sweeping
across any other questions
so the question is there is a large
telescope but a really really cool
mirror design that it is when the first
light is really soon if it's not already
happened LSST which has also made some
wonderful contributions to the open
source software for astronomy LSST is
really cool and the question is how do
how does cannot these fit into a world
where we have these giant projects that
are doing big surveys like LSST and and
tasks and all these other projects going
on and that's a great question and the
answer is we really complement each
other because LSST is amazing but it can
only see a portion of the sky so it sits
in there's only one LSST it's going to
be in the southern hemisphere art is
there and it's dark only half the time
and sometimes it's cloudy and like
they're a problem so it can't look at
the sky all the time and one of the
things we want to do with conoces is we
want to have a 24/7 observation of ever
on the planet so everywhere this cloudy
dad panopticon it's gonna stay asleep
during the night but in other places it
will be observing so we want to get a
much more continuous sample of low
quality samples from the sky so we will
have data able to be able to complement
and potentially fill in holes for the
time that Ellis's tea is not observing
and LSST I actually don't know much
about the kinds of things as he's gonna
look at it'll have much much higher
resolution than we do so it might not
even be looking at the same kinds of
exoplanets although it certainly be
capable of it
so we will be able to complement each
other and one of the cool things about
the current time in astronomy is a lot
of people are doing just that there's a
lot of researchers who don't actually
reserve any time on a telescope they
just go out there and find existing
surveys and take the data and sometimes
those surveys have embargo so they might
have to use older data like if you
wanted you could go download the Kepler
data today and go look for new
exoplanets and people are starting to
fuse the data from multiple sources in
multiple surveys and it make new
discoveries which is super exciting so
we'd love to be part of any project that
does that so yeah I'd be super excited
someone's like I want to match this up
with all SST data that's great here's
the data
thank you any other questions
so is there is there a an air quality
that just like quality that's so bad
that's a good question so I would say
that it's probably not going to be too
effective in a location sorry like we
can be done shorter exposure so what we
can do is as the light pollution gets
worse we do shorter exposures and we
have some samples and places where it
didn't work at all it's like if you set
it up in the middle of LA are we said I
went up in like basically the middle of
Pasadena once didn't work too well like
you should only see about 10 stars where
we were doing it but we're targeting
like magnitude 5 and and lower because
they're negative
no I guess positive so make su 5 and
higher stars so I we don't have enough
samples yet to determine where is that
place where it's not going to be the
right threshold but I live in San
Francisco so that would be a really fun
thing for me to do so thank you for the
inspiration I think I might drag mine
around on read you the polar alignment
over and over again and find out exactly
where it's gonna work well wear it well
because that would be really useful data
that we just don't have yet all right
well I'm officially out of time so I'm
gonna wrap up but thanks a lot for
coming
feel free to ask me questions later and
the limited time left and thanks a lot
[Applause]